Two, three, four!
Oh, wait.
We almost forgot about
our special guest.
Helpsters!
- K.Flay!
Helpsters, we start looping
our sounds when K.Flay tells us
and then stop
when she stops singing.
Sound good?
- Sounds great!
Go for it, Heart.
[HEART VOCALIZES]
Your turn, Mister Primm.
[MISTER PRIMM VOCALIZES]
Now you, Cody.
[CODY VOCALIZES]
Scatter.
[SCATTER VOCALIZES]
[ALL VOCALIZING]
♪ I like pencils. ♪
♪ And that's because
I like to draw. ♪
♪ I like pencils. ♪
♪ And I can draw
anything at all. ♪
♪ I can draw a spoon,
I can draw a tree, ♪
♪ I can draw anything
that’s in front of me. ♪
♪ I can draw my pencil
if I choose, ♪
♪ and then I get to use
another pencil. ♪
♪ 'Cause I like pencils. ♪
♪ I like pencils. ♪
[VOCALIZING STOPS]
Oh, thank you so much
for making music with us,
K.Flay!
Thank you, Helpters.
You're very welcome.
♪ Helpsters! ♪
♪